d'un coin de l'Afrique du futur
était acceptée dans la meilleure université de la galaxie,
à des planètes de là ?
Et si elle décidait d'y aller ?
Voici un extrait de ma trilogie de nouvelles « Binti » :
J'ai allumé le transporteur et récité une prière silencieuse.
J'ignorais ce que je ferais s'il ne fonctionnait pas.
Il était bon marché
même une goutte d'humidité ou, plus probablement, un grain de sable
pouvait provoquer un court-circuit.
Il était défectueux et la plupart du temps
je devais le redémarrer plusieurs fois avant qu'il ne fonctionne.
« Par pitié, pas maintenant. », ai-je pensé.
Le transporteur a frémi dans le sable et j'ai retenu mon souffle.
Petit, plat et noir telle une pierre de prière,
il a bourdonné doucement puis est lentement ressorti du sable.
Finalement, il a soulevé les bagages.
J'ai souri.
Je pouvais arriver à la navette à temps.
J'ai essuyé de l'otijze de mon front avec mon index et me suis agenouillée,
puis j'ai touché le sable avec mon doigt,
plaquant au sol l'argile rouge à l'odeur sucrée.
« Merci », ai-je murmuré.
Il fallait marcher 800 mètres sur la sombre route désertique.
Avec le transporteur, j'arriverais à temps.
En me redressant, j'ai marqué une pause et fermé les yeux.
Le poids de ma vie entière reposait sur mes épaules.
Je défiais les parties de moi les plus traditionnelles
pour la première fois de ma vie.
Je partais en pleine nuit, ils n'en avaient aucune idée.
Mes neuf frères et sœurs, tous plus âgés que moi sauf ma sœur et mon frère cadets,
ne verraient rien venir.
Mes parents n'imagineraient jamais que je ferais une chose pareille.
D'ici à ce qu'ils réalisent ce que j'avais fait et où j'allais,
j'aurais quitté la planète.
En mon absence, mes parents ronchonneraient entre eux
que je n'allais jamais remettre un pied chez eux.
Mes six oncles et tantes qui vivaient en bas de la rue
crieraient et jaseraient ensemble
quant à comment j'avais scandalisé toute la lignée.
J'allais être une paria.
« Allez », ai-je doucement murmuré au transporteur,
en tapant du pied.
Les fins anneaux d'argent que je portais autour des chevilles ont tinté,
mais j'ai retapé du pied.
Une fois allumé, le transporteur marchait mieux quand je ne le touchais pas.
« Allez », ai-je répété, de la sueur se formant sur mon front.
Comme rien n'a bougé,
j'ai donné un coup dans les deux valises placées au sommet du champ de force.
Elles ont bougé doucement et j'ai soupiré de soulagement.
J'avais au moins la chance de mon côté.
Dans une partie lointaine de l'Afrique,
Binti est un génie mathématique du groupe ethnique Himba.
Elle a été acceptée dans une université sur une autre planète
et a décidé d'y aller.
Emportant le sang de son peuple dans ses veines,
parée des enseignements, manières, même de la terre sur sa peau,
Binti quitte la Terre.
Alors que son histoire progresse, elle ne devient pas autre, mais davantage.
L'idée de partir mais d'apporter et de devenir davantage
est l'un des cœurs de l'afro-futurisme,
ou simplement un autre genre de science-fiction.
Je peux développer la différence entre science-fiction et afro-futurisme
en utilisant l'analogie de la pieuvre.
Comme les humains,
les pieuvres font partie des créatures les plus intelligentes sur Terre.
Cependant, l'intelligence des pieuvres a évolué d'une autre lignée de l'évolution
séparée de celle des êtres humains,
donc les fondations sont différentes.
Il en va de même pour les fondations de différentes formes de science-fiction.
La science-fiction spécule beaucoup
sur les technologies, les sociétés, les problèmes sociaux,
ce qu'il y a au-delà de notre planète ou dans notre planète.
La science-fiction est l'une des formes les plus efficaces
d'écriture politique.
Tout se rapporte à la question « Et si ? ».
Mais toute la science-fiction n'a pas la même lignée ancestrale,
cette lignée étant la science-fiction de racine occidentale,
qui est majoritairement blanche et masculine.
Nous parlons d'Isaac Asimov, de Jules Verne,
d'H.G. Wells, de George Orwell, de Robert Heinlein, etc.
Et si un Américano-Nigérien écrivait de la science-fiction ?
En grandissant, je ne lisais pas trop de science-fiction.
Je n'étais pas concernée par ces histoires préoccupées par la xénophobie,
la colonisation et la vision des extraterrestres comme différents.
Je ne voyais aucun reflet de quelqu'un me ressemblant dans ces récits.
Dans la trilogie « Binti »,
Binti quitte la planète à la recherche d'éducation auprès d'extraterrestres.
Elle part comme elle est,
avec son style,
emmenant ses cultures,
étant qui elle est.
J'ai été inspirée pour écrire ça
non pas parce que je suivais une lignée de récits classiques d'opéra de l'espace,
mais du fait de l'importance du sang,
de la famille, des conflits culturels
et du besoin de voir une Africaine quitter la planète à sa guise.
Ma science-fiction a d'autres ancêtres,
des ancêtres africains.
Je suis Américano- Nigérienne.
Je suis née de deux parents Nigériens immigrants
et j'ai été élevée aux États-Unis,
l'un des lieux de naissance de la science-fiction classique.
Mais c'est mon héritage nigérian qui m'a poussée à écrire de la science-fiction.
En particulier ces voyages en famille au Nigéria vers 1990.
Très jeune, j'y retournais avec ma famille.
Ces voyages m'ont inspirée.
D'où le fait que la première histoire que j'ai écrite ait lieu au Nigéria.
J'ai surtout écrit du réalisme magique et de la fantaisie
inspirés par mon amour pour l'igbo
et d'autres cosmologies et spiritualités traditionnelles de l'Afrique de l'Ouest.
Cependant, à la fin des années 90,
j'ai commencé à remarquer le rôle de la technologie au Nigéria :
la télévision par câble et les portables dans le village,
419 escrocs occupant les cyber-cafés,
le petit générateur connecté à l'ordinateur de bureau de mon cousin
car l'électricité allait et venait.
Mon côté américain me rendait assez différente
pour être intriguée par ces choses considérées comme normales
par la majorité des Nigérians.
Ma fascination a fini par donner naissance à des histoires.
J'ai ouvert d'étranges portes.
Et si les extraterrestres venaient à Lagos, au Nigéria ?
Voici un extrait de mon roman « Lagon ».
Tout le monde l'a vu,
partout dans le monde.
C'était une vraie introduction au terrible chaos ayant lieu à Lagos,
au Nigéria, en Afrique de l'Ouest, en Afrique, ici.
Car tant de personnes à Lagos avaient des appareils portables,
chargeables, brillants, vibrants, pépiants, tweetants,
communicants, connectés,
pratiquement tout était filmé et posté en ligne d'une façon ou d'une autre,
rapidement.
Le monde humain moderne est connecté tel une toile d'araignée.
Le monde regardait.
Il regardait empli d'une horreur fascinée,
pour avoir les informations,
mais surtout pour se divertir.
Des images de ce qu'il se passait dominaient les actualités internationales,
les sites de partage de vidéos, les réseaux sociaux,
les cercles, les pyramides et les trapézoïdes.
Mais l'histoire va plus loin.
C'est dans la boue,
la poussière,
la terre,
dans les bons souvenirs du cosmos terrestre.
C'est dans le passé, le présent et le futur, toujours entremêlés.
C'est dans l'eau.
C'est dans les puissants esprits et ancêtres résidant à Lagos.
C'est dans le cœur et l'esprit dans gens du Lagos.
Le changement engendre le changement.
L'extraterrestre Ayodele le savait.
Tout son peuple le savait.
C'est une voix d'Udide, la suprême artiste araignée,
plus vieille que la terre
et qui vit dans la terre sous la ville de Lagos,
écoutant et commentant
et tissant l'histoire d'une venue extraterrestre à Lagos.
À la fin, l'immense araignée qui faisait la taille d'une maison
et était responsable du tissage du passé, du présent et du futur,
décide d'apparaître et de prendre part à l'histoire.
Comme Udide, l'araignée artiste,
le sang de la science-fiction africaine descend profond
et il est vieux,
il est prêt à apparaître
et quand il le fera,
imaginez les nouvelles technologies, idées et changements socio-politiques
qu'il inspirera.
Pour les Africains, la science-fiction fait maison sera une volonté de puissance.
Et si ?
C'est une question puissante.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)